got some blue going on where is that
inspiration coming from
i don't know i like a little edge and a
little pop in my hair so i wanted to add
something different especially for the
teen vogue party
that's selena gomez's latest tick tock
video and in case that sound feels
familiar it's because
it is got some blue going on
yep that's a 15 year old selena in 2007
at the teen vogue young hollywood party
living her best teenage life with some
as she says
edgy blue streaks in her hair fast
forward over a decade
and here's a nearly 29 year old selena
poking fun
at her younger self got some blue going
on
where's that inspiration coming from i
don't know i like a little edge and a
little pop in my hair so i wanted to add
something different especially for the
teen vogue party
gotta hand it to selena the triple
threat clearly has a good sense of humor
about herself
she captioned the video quote to my
younger self
you're not cool bro got some blue going
on
where is that inspiration coming from i
don't know i like a little edge and a
little pop in my hair so i wanted to add
something different especially for the
teen vogue party
the triple threat seems to be having
lots of fun creating
tick-tock videos not only does she lift
up
her own videos but she does other
popular ones too
like this viral prank oh i can't believe
myself bro
i really got her pregnant bro like [ __ ]
that stupid thing
oh my girlfriend's getting mad
god who pregnant
as long as it's not me as long as
it's not me that kid is gonna have a big
ass nose
it's not my problem what [ __ ] miami
here i come
cause i'm not nobody's baby mama
she's also shown us her fitness routine
flexed her dancing skills
and proving she really is just like us
here's selena
singing in the car last night was the
last night and my past life got me here
like you can never figure me
[Music]
but the one that arguably takes the cake
this throwback video selena posted
vintage footage of her as a kid singing
along to britney spears's song
don't go knocking on my door
[Music]
aside from selena's thriving tick tock
page the entertainer is also busy doing
what she does
best in march she dropped her spanish
language ep
[Music]
revelacion
[Music]
she's also running her cosmetics lying
rare beauty
hey guys it's selena gomez the founder
of rare beauty
today i'm going to be sharing my rare
routine
with you along with some of my favorite
products from
my new summer collection and soon you'll
hear her
again as mavis in the upcoming animated
comedy
hotel transylvania transfermania
and co-starring alongside steve martin
and martin
short in the hulu series only murders in
the building
i'm excited but when it comes to
selena's personal life
a source told et in june that the singer
is in no rush to start dating or
settle down instead she's prioritizing
her mental health
and career quote selena has continued to
stay focused
and busy in terms of her life and career
she's in a great place and really feels
like she knows herself at this point
she wants to ensure that she's doing
things that help her mental health
and personal well-being she has been
working so much on herself over the
years
she wants to make sure that she's in a
safe and confident space altogether
before jumping into dating anyone
[Music]
seriously